hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
los trabajadores migrantes en el mundo
representan una fuerza laboral
importante en los países que los acogen
y su aporte es crucial para el
desarrollo se emplean en trabajos
esenciales donde hacen falta fuerza
laboral o en plazas que los locales no
quieren cubrir pero en muchos casos las
condiciones de sus contratos de trabajo
no son buenas en españa la
discriminación salarial golpea
particularmente a los latinos según
datos recientes del instituto nacional
de estadística- ganan un aproximado de
11 mil dólares estadounidenses menos de
salario anual que la población nacional
desde madrid' nuestra corresponsal laura
campo junto a julia corta y lía cabos
prepararon el siguiente informe
fin del día difícil para el venezolano
leandro trabaja como mecánico en un
garaje pero no gana el mismo sueldo que
sus compañeros españoles pues yo gano
800 euros al mes y un español ahorita
mismo en ese trabajo se ganaría a 1500
compañero mío gana 1500 leandro trabaja
irregularmente pero esa brecha salarial
también golpea a los trabajadores
declarados en españa los
latinoamericanos ganan de media
37% menos que el resto de la población
del país
el compañero mío gana más que yo cuando
yo trabajo igual que él me parece como
injusto y me siento súper mal pero ya
que voy a ser yo necesito el trabajo y
esta discriminación se puede observar
desde la búsqueda de trabajo en internet
armando ve cada día decenas de ofertas
especialmente para latinos unos anuncios
ilegales en españa se busca chico latino
con buena actitud y cero pena para
trabajar con trajes robots en las calles
de madrid al poner este tipo de anuncios
para latinos asumen que tú tienes una
necesidad de buscar trabajo urgente y
que tira a regalar
independientemente de que vayan a abusar
de tu varios sindicatos luchan contra
esta discriminación pero según ellos ni
siquiera la obtención de la nacionalidad
española cambia las cosas vamos en las
personas que tienen doble nacionalidad
española y otra
ganan menos que los que tienen
nacionalidad española solo tú podrás
enseñar tu carné de identidad pero tu
cara tus rasgos
tus apellidos tu lugar de nacimiento
seguirán diciendo
que eres extranjera o por lo menos les
seguirán diciendo a determinados
empresarios que es extranjera y te
tratarán como italianos para luchar
contra esto recomienda aumentar los
controles en las empresas y facilitar la
homologación de títulos de género le
suman en turquía la situación de los
trabajadores extranjeros es similar la
llegada de afganos tras la toma del
poder por parte de los talibanes
agudizaría a las malas condiciones
laborales de los migrantes ante una
eventual mayor oferta en la actualidad
se estima que 300 mil afganos residen en
el país juegan en contra también los
sentimientos antiinmigrantes en turquía
que incluso han terminado en violencia
nazar llegó cuando tenía 19 años a
turquía
ahora con 23 trabaja en una granja y es
el encargado del cuidado del ganado
micro por la guerra en su natal
afganistán pero no descarta retornar
algún día mientras tanto vive a gusto y
agradece por su trabajo en una localidad
cerca de la frontera con grecia
mean pan agua todo lo que necesite vean
mi dinero le envió dinero a mi familia
todos los meses son muy buenos estoy
satisfecho con el trabajo
pero a pesar de estar satisfecho muchos
de los 4 millones de migrantes
residentes en turquía son víctimas de
explotación por parte de sus empleadores
legisladores locales aseguran que es
difícil verificar las condiciones de
vida de los migrantes no registrados que
generalmente trabajan en el sector
textil o agrícola
están viviendo en condiciones humanas se
les dio un rincón en un granero y
vivieron en ese tipo de lugares se le
dio un calentador de agua y pueden
bañarse y comer en un lugar adecuado no
lo sabemos pero si el estado no les ha
otorgado legalmente permiso de trabajo a
estas personas y si estas personas no
han entra legalmente al país no se
pueden controlar los aspectos humanos ni
sus condiciones de trabajo
la realidad es que no cuentan con
garantías sociales ni de salud
para abogados en el país la labor que
realizan se paga muy por debajo de un
salario mínimo normal
estas personas no tienen seguridad
social el tiempo normal de trabajo de
una persona es de siete y media ocho
horas máximo las horas restantes deben
dedicarse a actividades sociales y
descanso creo que es un crimen contra la
humanidad emplear a estas personas desde
las cinco o seis de la mañana hasta las
siete u ocho de la noche todos los días
durante seis a siete meses sin
vacaciones la mayoría de los migrantes
que residen en turquía son sirios pero
el número de extranjeros aumentaría
considerablemente con la llegada de
afganos al territorio
la organización internacional del
trabajo estima que son unos 169 millones
de trabajadores migrantes
internacionales en el mundo las mujeres
constituyen el 41 5% y los hombres el
58,5 las trabajadoras se enfrentan más
obstáculos a la hora de conseguir un
empleo e incluso pueden sufrir
discriminación por cuestiones de género
hasta que inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]